waiting and hoping
even if the chances are very slim zainab
has been sitting here every day since
the earthquakes hit comforted Now by one
of her daughters
my daughter son-in-law and three
grandchildren are still under there they
found some of their personal belongings
they went into their rooms but couldn't
find them we've been here since the
earthquake happened they cannot find
them
among these destroyed buildings this
school remains standing
it's being used to provide people with
Aid
there is no one left to go to school a
lot of people have died only a few
people are left
at least the schools are being used for
a good purpose our education has been
suspended and it will affect us badly
but I'm sure the state will do what is
necessary for our education
in another part of this devastated City
this camp set up to house displaced
people is now full of children
we are very concerned about our kids
education we want their education to
start as soon as possible this was the
epicenter of the earthquakes and it will
never be the same again with so many
buildings destroyed and even more
damaged it's unlikely children in this
city will be returning to school anytime
soon but after providing the initial aid
for the earthquake victims the
government is now turning its attention
to what comes next foreign